mais on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés j'ai l'imam directeur du
mensuel afrique magazine bonjour
serviront soir face à vous gauthier
rybinski la rédaction de france 24
bonjour gauthier des parlementaires de
buddh où l'on minutes et qui
applaudissent à tout rompre la même
scène se répète invariablement de
capitale en capitale depuis maintenant
un mois depuis que la russie a envahi
l'ukraine et que volodymyr zelensky us
de la meilleure arme à sa disposition la
communication c'est depuis kiev où par
la force des choses le président
ukrainien est confiné dans son bunker
qu'ils interpellent les dirigeants
occidentaux
prenons leurs leur opinion publique à
témoin comme aujourd'hui en france ou
par visioconférence volodine zelensky a
comparé la ville martyre de marioupol à
verdun avant d'appeler les dernières
enseignes françaises encore présente à
quitter la russie écouter
les chars les armes anti-char les avions
de combat les défenses aériennes vous
pouvez nous aider nous en avons besoin
pour que la liberté ne perdent pas le
monde doit nous soutenir avec des
sanctions contre l'agresseur chaque
semaine un nouveau paquet de sanctions
les entreprises françaises doivent
quitter le marché russe rno leroy merlin
auchan et autres ils doivent cesser
d'être les sponsors de la machine de
guerre russe
voilà lors des remerciements pour les
déjà prodigué doublé d'un appel à une
nouvelle aide supplémentaire et danané
man cible le procédé se répète chez
zelensky il est vraiment efficace pour
faire bouger les politiques occidentaux
gauthier alors ça dépend effectivement
le ton qu'il acquit la docte et à qui
ils s'adressent en avait bien vu que
devant le faro où députés allemands du
bundestag il avait été assez virulent il
leur avait mis quelques paires de baffes
il faut le dire est que la en france il
a un peu ménager la chèvre et le chou se
disant qu'après tout si il devait y
avoir un système naissant qui verrait un
certain nombre de pays de l'otan assuré
une certaine garantie de sécurité à
l'ukraine sans avoir justement
l'ensemble de l'otan si la france
faisait partie de ça il s'agissait pas
de la deûle a brocardé trop maintenant
est ce que c'est vraiment efficace je ne
sais pas parce que
au fond aux élèves qui emploient des
thèmes des concepts qui sont
parfaitement légitimes est-ce que nous
est ce que notre représentation est
encore capable
d'apprécier de goûter la substance de
cette heure je ne sais pas on écoute et
juste après sa déclaration interventions
de certains députés comme par exemple le
candidat d'extrême droite nicolas dupont
aignan qui disait c'est un discours
émouvant mais au fond ça n'a pas
d'autres importance moi je veux la paix
alors d'accord vous me direz que la
france traditionnellement est réputé en
cas de conflit pour produire une
quantité impressionnante de capitulards
mais enfin c'est quand même pas
uniquement la raison pour laquelle si
vous voulez un président ukrainien qui
est dans la panade s'adresse aux
français donc est ce que tout le monde a
noté qu'il y avait eu une petite baisse
je sais pas de forme de morale c'est
possible aussi mais je pense qu'il a
plutôt orienté la chose vers une
proposition
française qui devait être vers une
attitude française qui devait être moins
bousculé que les allemands par exemple
sachant que aussi emmanuel macron a
toujours une forme de liens de téléphone
rouge je sais pas comment l'appeler mais
avec vladimir poutine mais il a redit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il va
s'entretenir notre le président russe
qu'avez-vous pensez vous de son discours
je pense que c'est une
c'est une stratégie et sert qui il a
cette efficacité en termes de
communication ils parlent à la
représentation française mais je pense
qu'il parle à l'opinion publique c'est à
dire il sait que il sait que l'opinion
publique est
heurtée traumatisés par les images qui
viennent d'ukraine il sait qu'il a
besoin que c'est ce que ses opinions
publiques ce soit en france en allemagne
ou dans l'union européenne aux états
unis etc restent mobilisées sur le
dossier qui est pas de fatigue des
opinions devant ces images donc il faut
absolument j'allais dire martelé le
discours je suis assez d'accord à
gauthier c'est que les français ont été
un peu épargnées sauf sur la question
des entreprises quand même qui est une
question assez précise et puis surtout
pour qu'on continue à alimenter
l'ukraine en armes en
soutiens divers et variés et ekoko
maintiennent aussi ce rideau de fer
vis-à-vis de moscou qui quand même on le
voit tous les jours ça ça tremble et
puis les russes sont pas peut-être que
les rues sont embourbés sur le plan
militaire mais il manque pas de lits
manquent pas d'alternative pour même
pour pauvre pauvre escalade et comme on
dit c'est le terme en ce moment le
conflit l'histoire de payer le gaz et le
pétrole en roubles bon ben voilà c'est
vrai c'est un vrai défi pour les
allemands ou qui ont 50 % de leurs
importations qui vient aussi non donc
voilà donc cesser cette comme la après
encore une fois je ne sais pas combien
de fois on peut répéter l'exercice s'est
on l'a fait un peu partout
il est isolé c'est de ces terribles
d'ailleurs puisque
ces images montrent l'isola les
isolations mais il a parlé aux opinions
publiques maintenant là le défi pour les
ukrainiens sait comment installer dans
la durée puisque on s'oriente
visiblement vers quelque chose qui va
durer comment installer le soutien
euro américain parce que là on est
vraiment sur ce territoire là dans la
durée vis-à-vis du gouvernement
ukrainien des astuces ukrainienne de
l'armée et s'est brisé l'instant en tout
cas qui cherchent un devant chaque
auditoire auquel il s'adresse à créer un
lien particulier par des références
communes lorsqu'il comme lorsqu'il
évoque à la mort naturelle de belmondo
par opposition à la mort brutale subie
d'un très grand nombre d'ukrainiens ou
qu'ils comparent marioupol aux ruines de
verdun gauthier ça parle aux français ça
aussi c'est artificiel à force de
multiplier ce type de d'analogie oui je
pense que ça devrait parler aux français
mais pour la même raison que celle
caveau keziah l'instant il n'est pas
certain alors de par la durée une part
de ce conflit mais aussi parce que nous
sommes on l'a bien vu à travers
certaines réactions ou les écrits de
confrères nous sommes tellement affadi
parfois par 77 ans de paix de démocratie
que on our à tendance forcément à dire
ce président zelensky il est bien
sympathique m'enfin avec ces grands mots
liberté égalité fraternité c'est comme
si nous mêmes nous n'étions plus
capables de mettre du contenu dans ces
valeurs là et dans ces préceptes là et
je pense que c'est là la difficulté des
hells qui parce qu'il pense s'adresser à
des gens qui sont attentifs ils sont
certes traumatisé je suis d'accord avec
ce que 10 jan mais est ce qu'ils en
tirent il s'attend à trouver du candidat
et du candidat il ne trouve que du
cynisme d'un vendeur il ne trouve que du
signal que tu suis le fait simplement
qu'ils nous qu'on ne tire pas les
conclusions de ce convoi vous aurez vous
savez très bien qu'en france vous êtes
quantité de personnes qui diront c'est
terrible ce qui se passe en ukraine
enfin c'est loin de chez nous et puis si
on y mettait pas les payer juste avant
ariès que cet élan de sympathie ziani ne
sortent pas à deux fondamentaux j'allais
dire un variable qui sont la non
intervention de l'occident face à une
puissance nucléaire qu'est la russie et
ça ça ne bougera pas et puis la non
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne parce que là eh bien on
brandy les traités pour dire c'est
impossible
on a dit dès le départ qu'on se battrait
pas pour kiev directement parce que
c'est une erreur de l'avoir dit je sais
pas si c'est une erreur et je prendrai
pas la responsabilité personnelle
d'avoir ce jugement tout ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'on sait que si on avait ouvert
un conflit direct dans le ciel ukrainien
on avait un risque majeur d' escalade
avec eux la russie est que les
américains et les européens ont dit en
gros ce n'est pas un enjeu vital qui
nécessite une telle prise de risque en
particulier sur le plan on va dire atom
il va d'une d'une éventuelle frappe
atomique
après on est quand même dans un monde
assez surréaliste parce que les russes
arrête pas de nous menacer de frappe
nucléaire qui eux mêmes se menacent eux
mêmes travers que premier cas un peu
plus sur le bouton a perdu en gros enfin
tout le monde perd donc tout ça reste
assez rhétorique méreau c'est que la
frontière est posée c'est à dire ce qui
est en-deça des frontières de l'otan
n'est pas une est un danger mais pas un
danger vital mais on a dit que si jamais
il y avait des attaques ou des
interventions sur le territoire de
l'otan on était plus dans la même
discussion donc voilà les frontières
sont posées la deuxième chose c'est que
ces efforts de communication c'est parce
que les sanctions vont peser aussi sur
les économies européennes elles vont
peser en particulier sur les économies
européennes qui n'ont pas de ressources
énergétiques on achète du gaz du pétrole
on peut pas s'en passer si on peut pas
les payer en route ça veut dire que il
va ya voir le chancelier sur le cela dit
il va y avoir des faillites en allemagne
ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir des pans
entiers de l'industrie allemande qui
vont être ralenti ça veut dire qu'il va
y avoir des récessions donc on est
engagé dans une course vous allez dire
de la douleur parce que les russes vont
payer cher et on va payer cher et qui va
à tenir le plus longtemps possible les
américains étant un petit peu derrière
parce que eux ils ont des matières
premières eux ils ont doublé pas ils ont
ils ont toutes sortes de moyens blé du
vrai blé devrait blé ils ont toutes
sortes de moyens de tenir et nous on est
exposé directement au contact déjà
physiquement et au contact les sanctions
elles vont pas ça va pas ça pas être
gratuit donc donc c'est pour ça que
c'est cette communication
cette tentative de mobiliser en
permanence les opinions publiques autour
de la cause ukrainienne c'est parce
qu'ils savent qu'au bout d'un moment ça
va peser aussi sur le coup va peser
aussi sur les opinions publiques à
emmanuel macron alertèrent y aura
peut-être cinq minutes après du coup
pour les autres pays qui sera justement
remparts les massages puisque emmanuel
macron alerté on s'en souvient c'était
en clôture du sommet de verte à
versailles il ya dix jours maintenant le
risque d'une crise alimentaire mondiale
la russie et l'ukraine fourni semble et
en orge et autres céréales à nombre de
pays du monde et notamment d'afrique
pour certains comme l'egypte la somalie
le bénin ont tant la rdc se sont même
allés prince il mûri fournisseurs dès
lors le risque d'une pénurie se fait
sentir on voit son image avec monia
cassen
les galettes de pain
incontournable des repas en egypte
devenue aussi un indicateur de la crise
alimentaire leurs prix ont augmenté de
25% conséquence de l'invasion russe en
ukraine car l'egypte est le plus gros
importateur de blé au monde et l'an
dernier 70 % de ces céréales provenaient
de russie et d'ukraine
aidé les tue très précisément à utiliser
dans le pain subventionné un pain qui
ensuite à 80 millions d'égyptiens qui
sont inscrits sur l'écart de deux
subventions et donc qui
pourrait ne pas en bénéficier en
quantité suffisante ch'ti on ne trouve
pas moyen d importer du blé la russie et
l'ukraine représente à elle seule un
tiers des exportations de céréales dans
le monde avec le blocage de ces ports le
cren ne peut plus exporter la récolte de
cette année est incertaine et les
sanctions prises contre la russie
devrait perturber les exportations
l'egypte n'est pas le seul pays à voir
ses réserves de céréales impacté le
kazakhstan la mongolie le liban ou
encore la turquie dépendent de la russie
et de l'ukraine à plus de 70% sur le
continent africain les craintes d'une
pénurie se font aussi ressentir en
somalie au bénin à madagascar ou encore
en république démocratique du congo en
tunisie aussi les boulangers voient
leurs stocks de farine ça me nuire les
conséquences pourraient être encore plus
grave au soudan où plus de 85% du blé du
pays provient de russie et d'ukraine
près d'un soudanais sur deux pourrait
souffrir de la faim cette année d'ici la
fin de l'année près de 20 millions de
personnes soit près de la moitié du pays
seront en situation d'insécurité
alimentaire
une insécurité alimentaire qui va de
pair avec l'inflation déjà fragilisée
par la crise sanitaire et l'instabilité
régionale de nombreux pays africains
pourraient voir leur économie sombrer un
peu plus macky sall président sénégalais
mais aussi de l'union africaine a
demandé mardi le soutien de la banque
mondiale et des partenaires
internationaux pour faire face aux
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
il faut dire que près existait déjà à la
guerre en ukraine un contexte de
sécheresse et et de hausse de 2 des prix
des liens serrés il ya il ya des
tensions structurelles sur les matches
faciles tout sur tous les produits
alimentaires depuis des années sellal le
changement climatique la démographie est
de plus en plus de consommateurs et est
le co vide est arrivée qui a perturbé
tout les j'allais dire les réseaux
d'approvisionnement normaux la
logistique donc tout ça ça s'accumule
petit à petit et d'un seul coup il ya
une crise politique et militaire et une
guerre qui supprime du marché
un tiers un tiers de la production et
donc encore une fois les pays riches
on à la marge on mangera peut-être un
peu moins de pain on mangera plus de
ceci ou plutôt ça mais il ya des pays en
particulier en afrique qui sont
directement exposés à des risques de
rupture le blé étant devenue une céréale
qui est d'ailleurs intéressant en
afrique le blé n'existait pas enfin on
n'a jamais mangé avant d'avoir la
colonisation on mangeait pas de blé
maintenant on mange du blé
mais dans les pays du maghreb c'est le
couscous et le pain enfin voilà donc
tout ça est impactée et ne faut pas
oublier que c'est des produits qui sont
souvent subventionnés déjà cercle des
caisses d'état subventionne des prix qui
étaient déjà élevés pour pas que les
populations en plein en pâtissent et
vous doublez à côté de ça à chaque
énergétique qui arrive à grande vitesse
parce que du pétrole à 120 dollars ou à
130 dollars pour des pays qui sont
importateurs de blé et qui ne sont pas
producteurs de pétrole ou d'une autre
énergie galles c'est l'asphyxié assuré
et l' asphyxie assuré c'est forcément un
moment ou un autre une crise politique
qui peut des braves qui peut déboucher
alors il ya beaucoup d'analystes vous
savez c'est une des analyses un peu
convenue des printemps arabes de 2011
c'était de dire que ça correspondait
exactement à un bon moi je pense qu'il y
avait une hausse des produits
alimentaires mais il y avait aussi je
veux dire à un contexte socio politique
interne qu'ikea qui s'est greffé mais là
à l'échéance de voilà quelques mois on
ne sait pas trop comment certains pays
mon pouvoir à la fois à payer leur
alimentation est payé leur énergie
gonier
wissant ans sans vouloir
exonérer les acteurs de ce conflit en
europe
quand même on vous voit que l'afrique a
toujours et est toujours
importatrice nette de denrées
alimentaires c'est à dire qu'il ya un
vrai problème d'autosuffisance
alimentaire alors que théoriquement
mêmes malgré la croissance démographique
on devrait pouvoir et en plus avec une
main d'oeuvre abondante arrivé à
déséquilibre alimentant bien même elle
le serait
l'ukraine et la russie sont aussi de
gros exportateurs d'engrais qui permet à
tout à fait aux produire pourrais tu as
fait mais un petit tiers des états
africains produisent leur propre aux
engrais donc il faut savoir ce qu'il
faut apprendre c'est comment ça se passe
là et pourquoi ça ne se passe pas
ailleurs ce qu'est ce qui est terrible
c'est que moi je suis assez d'accord il
ya la discussion sur l'agro l'agro
l'agriculture et l'agro-industrie en
afrique est une véritable discussion
parce que l'afrique aurait les moyens de
se nourrir elle-même et de les nourrir
une fois ci beaucoup mais pas ensemble
et d'autres céréales qui sont adaptées
au territoire le sorgho le mil externe
mais le blé on peut faire pousser un peu
au nord un petit peu au sud mais pas au
centre mais en admettant que ce discours
sur l'émancipation agricoles de
l'afrique mais ça prend pas ça se fait
pas en trois mois c'est c'est un débat
qui est maintenant est devenue une
réalité sur le terrain donc depuis
quelques années ça va prendre encore un
certain nombre d'années mais là on à
shorter mais comme disent les analystes
américains on a une crise à très court
terme qui va nécessiter du financement
de l'aide des appuis d'autant plus que
vous savez comment ça se passe dans ces
cas là les pays riches bon stocker oui
parce que l'egypte stockable ceux qui
ont les moyens vont stocker des données
et à de manière très immédiates là on
arrive dans le mois de ramadhan wauquiez
oui on craindre là aussi la nature
inflationniste inflationnistes walla les
saveurs de chez les filles ce qui peut
justement aussi être intéressant et ça
veut pas dire qu'on néglige le côté
concret de tous les jours de cette crise
pour les africains c'est aussi
l'interprétation politique que chaque le
pays où chaque personne en afrique va en
enfer est ce que ça sera quelque chose
qui vous on comprendra ce que peut-être
poutine l'agresseur ou est-ce qu'au
contraire on dira mais au fond ce sont
les occidentaux qui se sont mêlés d'une
affaire ou coupe poutine était légitime
dont il avait le la main et justement
c'est une preuve supplémentaire de cet
occident perturbé les largement nous
affament ça aussi ça peut être quelque
chose qui au delà évidemment de la crise
immédiate peut avoir son importance dans
les régimes politiques dont parlait tout
à l'heure il ya sur l'escaut l'asia une
lecture voilà qu'ils soient remises à
débiner occident qu'en afrique la
semaine dernière en afrique en afrique
de l'ouest s'est il ya pas une
incompréhension mais ça paraît loin ce
conflit paraît loin et paraît étrange et
à des contextes africains ce qui est
encore une fois plus ou moins faux parce
que d'une part il ya des impacts
directement économique et deuxièmement
on some les pays de choisir leur camp
et quand vous vous n'êtes pas dans le
plus du non alignés aujourd'hui
je peux vous dire qu entre moscou et
washington les pressions on l'a vu lors
du vote de l'assemblée générale des
nations-unies les dépressions sont très
fortes donc l'afrique est dedans elle
est complètement dedans après comme
comme dit gauthier la position
américaine helmand elle manque de
crédibilité morale
irak yémen syrie tout ça vous avez
laissé faire vous avez fait même l'irak
c'est vous vous avez tout que vous avez
tout péter vous avez tué madeleine
albright j'en prends une demi seconde
madeleine albright qui est un personnage
assez révéré aux états unis c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui est qui était en plein
dans les sanctions qui ont fait un mal
phénoménal population irakienne merci
gilles m'a dit qu'il faut absolument
rendre l'antenne voilà je vous remercie
en tout cas c'est le plus loin et merci
également à gauthier rybinski on se
retrouve dans trois minutes pour un
nouveau genre